be up there do a pump fake and then go  up and go strong Mitchell for three got  it hey this guy picked up the confidence  this watch his spin moves they take it  away he recovers comes down it fakes the  big guy  very good job he said five rebounds  three assists and 18 points Mitchell  again he's got balls Channel  in this house under Mitchell with 15  points here in the third quarter a  perfect 6 for 6 you'll be and he's  really using all his tricks well that's  a great spin movin and a step one scoop  off the glass and this one he's just  doing a great job have been on this boat  yeah he gives you the spin now instead  of stepping on this he created the space  by the fade and then gets the balance  look easy  he watch this move as he comes in as he  flips it up right handed into the  defensive man and he plays the glass how  about that